Deku might be the final user of one for
all one for all has been around for over
a hundred years and Deku is the ninth
user but there might never be a tenth
that's because one for all is a
stockpiling Quirk that just keeps
getting stronger over time we know that
anyone with a quirk who later inherits
one for all will have their lifespan
reduced the combined power of their own
Quirk factor and the one for all Quirk
Factor are too much for their body to
handle so the ideal candidate for
inheriting one for all is someone who is
quirkless when he first got the Quirk
Deku nearly killed himself every time he
tried to use it and then he took the
Quirk to a completely new level he
unlocked the quirks of the previous
users and became far stronger than these
previous users at this stage one for all
might be too powerful for any other user
to handle even if they were born
quirkless so Deku might never have a
successor